كان يكفي حساب اخر صندوق لتنفجر الساحات
في تركيا فرحا في الانتخابات الموصوفه
هناك بانتخابات القرن اندفع الملايين من
انصار رجب طيب اردوغان للاحتفال بعد معركه
انتخابيه حاميه شكلت اكبر تحد امام الرئيس
المثير للجدل للاعجاب للافتتان للبغض كل
ذلك معا وكل ذلك عابر للحدود
[موسيقى]
وما قول انما يجري في تركيا لا يمكن ان
يبقى في تركيا افتئات على الواقع فقد
تجاوز الموقف منها حدود علاقه اردوغان
بشعبه وقضاياها الداخليه وتشهد بذلك حمله
اعلاميه غربيه شديده بشرت بهزيمته ودعمت
معارضيه لتصدم بخسارتهم مرتين ويتهاوى من
بعض واسم حكمه بالديكتاتوريه امام طراره
لخوض انتخابات اعاده بسبب نصف نقطه مئويه
وتقف الصحافه نفسها تسال اليوم في حيره عن
سر الرئيس الذي لا يهزم لكن الاسئله
الاكبر كانت ترتسم في المحيط القريب عن سر
الشغف العربي خصوصا بمتابعه تلك
الانتخابات فلا يفهم لماذا تخرج المسيرات
في مدن عربيه ويفرح ملايين ويترقب غيرهم
او سحر الديمقراطيه ذاك الذي عبق الاجواء
في تلك الليله من ربيع العرب المنتطفئ
يمثل اردوغان تجربه تجاوزت حمولاتها
سياسيه العابره والمتغيره يهتم العرب
بانتخابات تركيا لوجود ملايين اللاجئين
فيها ارتبط مصيرهم ببقائه بسم الله الرحمن
الرحيم
وثم تهمه يتحدث عن دغدغه المشاعر
التاريخيه والدينيه حيث يظهر اردوغان
متماهيا معهيه ثقافيه اسلاميه وسط موجات
تغريب وتيه بعيد ان الكثيرين تمت معنا عام
وهو التجربه نفسها خاضت تركيا انتخابات
تضاهي بل تتفوق على انتخابات الغرب
الديمقراطي بنسبه المشاركه هذه انتخابات
الخمسين وقليلا في بحر التسعينات في المئه
تحت اسم جمهوريات عربيه حاول كثير من
شعوبها ان يصنع لصوته قيمه وذاك احساس
بالمواطنه والتفرد معبا بمعنى الكرامه
والحريه وبلغ من اهميته ان قوبل بثورات
مضاده اجهضت الاحلام ووقدت الاحساس ليس
غريبا ان يكون محركها العربي اكثر ما يبغض
ما حدث في تركيا
تبدو تجربه تركيا باردوغان اليوم وبغيره
غدا ما المحن مما تريده ملايين في الجوار
وبرهانا في امكان قيام نموذج ناجح
للديمقراطيه في شرق اوسط يتباهى الغرب
بزعم ان واحتها دوله احتلال هذا بلد مسلم
قريب نامن وصاعد استطاع شعبه وفعل فلما لا
نفعل لكم يبدو السؤال بسيطا ومخيفه